[Musica]
[Applauso]
io sono arrivato a napoli quasi 50 anni
fa
e mi sono innamorato della città
nazione e intelligenze della sua gente
e poi ho conosciuto isole e mi sono
innamorato di ischia
doti che sono di
moro facilmente ma non è così
mi sono innamorato di ischia che chiamo
la mia isola crepacuore
per i suoi colori
preso profumi e sapori
mio suocero mi portavo i fichi
non le offriva che ha messo fossero
immettere dei gay
e lo erano
purtroppo gli schermi ha fatto conoscere
anche altre crepe
le crepe del terremoto di quasi cinque
anni fa
quando è successo il terremoto
noi eravamo come la terra scossi
abbiamo guardato l'abisso
abbiamo visto la nostra fragilità
eccole della terra
però il sesso tempo la nostra mente il
nostro cuore al nostro volontario tutti
aperti
perché quando poi di tutto da qualche
parte deve compri cominciare
allora ho proposto ad alcuni terremotati
di osare la teoria
la teoria
non è tanto una teoria è più un
approccio alla trasformazione
dell'istituzione
dell'organizzazione e delle persone in
organismi
apprendente
io l'ho usato con papi comune qualche
protettore qualche scuola e funziona
sempre
viene da dal lavoro di professione
professore di storia economica apporto
sharma delle matia prestigiose
università di post e del suo gruppo che
ha formato da studiosi che tanti materie
ma anche di artisti
e con questo doppio binario riesce fare
cose meravigliose
di non far creare una comunità globale
di agenti al cambiamento
lo charme parte dalla premessa
noi esseri umani
siamo soffrendo di tre disconnessioni
la disconnessione con la natura
come società
e col nostro potenziale più alto
io avevo sentito dei tanti progetti che
mette insieme ambiente e società ma non
avevo mai sentito parlare del nostro
potenziale più alto
di noi in quanto individui o di noi in
quanti sistemi nei quali siamo immersi
mi sembrava molto intrigante come
impostazione
8 sharm ha fatto tanti studi sui nono
innovatori
e ha trovato che quello che conta è lo
stato interiore di chi propone il
cambiamento
e non suggerisce
suggerisce
di usare cannocchiale di galileo gun
canon lei
di farlo girare verso di noi
e di farci entrare
in questo processo della u
il punto a
propone osservare osservare osservare
osservare come guardiamo le cose
salva recami ascoltiamo la già promosso
la scott che noia creiamo uno spazio per
gli altri
e osservare cammino interagiamo
con questi approcci
ai consigli di entrare nella parte più
profonda della ue al punto b
e di entrare in quello spazio sacro che
abbiamo
di silenzio di stare
pienamente nel presente non è passato e
nel futuro
esclusivamente nel presente
e di vedere quali sogni soffitti
riemergono quali other scartate
ricompaiono
e con questi
piccoli problemi queste
e agili e un istante non per fare
qualcosa di enorme e di vedere se questi
piccoli idee embrioni che
possono fiorire questi germogli se posso
inventare dei fiori
avrei raccontato questo ai miei
o prenotati e sono rimasti entusiasti
però quattro mesi dopo quando noi ci
siamo rivisti per cercare di dare le
gambe a qualche progetto non solo a
cominciare a pensare a qualcosa
non so perché noi
i tre nemici della trasformazione
erano comparsi
sono
la voce giudicante
che credi di essere
la voce del cinismo ma che celava a fare
la voce della paura
c'è possiamo fare noi
allora quando arrivo i nemici non c'è
niente da fare
allora io ho lasciato cadere quella
proposta e sono andati in giro nel paese
perché facendo parte dall'associazione
italiano per la partecipazione pubblica
ho l'occasione di vedere tantissimi
progetti e ce ne sono di eccellenti del
paese
il problema è che non vengono una rotto
comunicati e non vengono spesso
replicati ma sono gli e sono un tesoro
per tutti noi
allora voi pensate questo non per marta
ed è qui che è vero un pochino
però io no
visto che noi abbiamo vissuto questi due
anni di pandemia
io credo che noi siamo cambiati un
pochino siamo diventati molto più
consapevoli di quanto siamo
interconnessi e quanto abbiamo i bisogni
degli altri
con viso voglio farvi entrare
quel punto c
in quello spazio sacro che ognuno di noi
ha con via vi chiedo se siete disposti a
seguirmi nella
quindi
metaphor mani sulle ginocchia
i piedi ben piantati sulla terra
chiudete gli occhi
respirati profondi veramente
sentito come se ci fossero delle radici
che vanno dalle vostre ai vostri piedi
che vanno giù
più
giù
e sperati e profondamente
poi saliti al cuore
aprite il cuore
prima di tutto a voi stessi
noi tutti abbiamo bisogno
aprite il vostro cuore all'isola
aprite il vostro cuore a tutti organismi
che sono nel mare
e intorno al mare
questa l'idea alla testa
alzate la testa fino al cielo
sognarti il vostro potenziale più alto
sogniamo in un nostro potenziale più
alto
apriamo gli occhi
torniamo al negombo
e non vi chiedo di dirmi
quali sono
le piccole proposte vostre le proposte
embryonic e
non quelle più intime
ma se ce ne sono
di più pubbliche
piccolo di scrivere quando uscite
c'è una lavagna all'ingresso
vediamo se possiamo costruire qualcosa
insieme
se possiamo seguire cinque tappe della
ue
a
iniziare insieme
anche con le voci contrarie
beh
sentire rubarci dal territorio
di tornare in quello spazio
intimo ma in modo un po più collettivo
fare qualcosa di concreto
e fosse coinvolgere insieme
anche la più piccola idea può generare
qualcosa
ma non dimenticate quello che dice
l'enac coin
c'è una crepa in ogni cosa
e attraverso la crepa
che passa la luce
trans
[Applauso]